اصداء هذه الانتخابات التركيه التي تمتد
الى دول الجوار الاوروبيه فطبعا مشاهدينا
اوروبا التي تتقاسم الجغرافيا مع تركيا
تراقب عن كثب ما ستسفر عنه هذه الجوله فما
هي الملفات الاوروبيه التي ترتبط بنتيجه
هذه الانتخابات طبعا تاتي في طلعتها مساله
انضمام السويد الى حلف الناتو صحيفه
في حال فوز اردوغان الصحيفه توقعت ايضا ان
يستغل اردوغان هذه الورقه من اجل الضغط
على واشنطن وحلفائها على الطرف الاخر فان
مخاوف السويد قد تتبدد في حاله فوزك لتجدد
فالمعارضه تبدو اكثر ليونه في التعامل مع
المطالب الاوروبيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات